[Music]
do
i'm talking about pre-processor
preprocessor asts
harder to say than i thought
asts stands for abstract syntax tree
i'll go into uh that more if you're
you're not familiar with it but i just
thought i'd get that out of the way up
front
um
i would get striped now uh so
that's outdated um i think i have one
more bulleted list but my style's a
little different and
uh it's actually not different at all
from the way i used to do presentations
so it's completely useless information
for you
uh anyways uh abusing and hacking is is
a term i'm using in this presentation to
mean uh
using something for a reason outside of
its intended uh purpose
uh oh that's their correct size how
about
this html slides for the win um
so this is i think some sas or scss um
specifically and uh it's kind of like
a fairly declarative syntax so what is
there to hack what is there to abuse
uh with just some text that turns into
css right so uh it's not necessarily an
obvious place when you're talking code
you can say like oh i can inject this
here or inject that there but you're
limited by syntax here and it's not
necessarily even like i guess it is
touring complete uh especially like
checked and stuff i think ryan's got to
talk about that but so so the place that
we're going to try and inject ourselves
is in the compilation step um so how
does this
uh sas so it's just a
smaller part of of this same thing turn
into actual css right so how do we take
that variable pull it out and then put
it in the right place to output actually
decent css
parsing and compiling
so how does parsing work so let's narrow
it down even further we just have a
single variable declaration uh in sas um
and naturally sas is uh ruby
um and i don't really program ruby so
most of mine will be in javascript so
sorry if you're a ruby fan uh so parsing
uh
i can i can talk about it on a high
level here and that's just like know
about the syntax rules of the language
and go through and assign
what everything is this is a variable
declaration or this is uh even more
specifically a string or a value or a
semicolon right uh figure out all those
different parts
so inside this little little guy we have
the the variable prefix we can look for
the dollar sign and we know that hey
this is about to be a variable and we
know it's going to be a variable until
we hit like white space or a semicolon
in this case we get the variable name
it's blue and then we hit a semicolon
then we can have as much white space as
we want
and then we get some random string and
that's going to be the value
most of the time css
will let you put anything in there as
long as it's not like the semicolon or
another colon or something like that so
any
non-invalid character there is going to
be the value so it might not actually be
anything to the browser but it would be
valid uh and then
obviously the the rule delimiter
so this is how this would parse down
uh whenever
sas was was pulling this in
uh more specifically uh it does that
programmatically so it's gonna go
through and check every possibility of
each thing um of each character that it
gets to uh and so this is the the most
simple parser that i could write on a
single slide uh you have a result
array and you just want to push each
token onto the array so you say uh i hit
a semicolon push the semicolon token
which in this case is the string
semicolon probably would not work out
well
um
but you go through and then you you end
up with a list of each of the tokens so
rather than having just random text
strings you know like hey this is a
variable this is a rule delimiter this
is a value and this is a rule uh
ending statement
more realistically most people are going
to write a parser expression um a
generator a peg a parser expression
generator is is what this is and you
don't have to know anything about this i
just wanted to make sure i was being
realistic uh you kind of define that
like hey a class is a dot followed by an
identifier and then whenever i get this
just give me this object back and then a
computer will generate a parser for you
so you don't have to write all those
like reverse while loops and do a look
ahead and all that stuff so
if you are looking into writing your own
parser i'd probably suggest starting at
a parser expression generator so you
just write the grammar uh and
uh it generates the parser much more
simple
so when you're done you need to
represent the code as data instead of
your text so now we have somewhere in
between there we have like here are what
all of our symbols are we have tokens uh
if you will uh so so this first becomes
this so we have the the variable start
which is that dollar sign we have a
string uh which is blue uh that's
technically like the variable name then
we have like the equals operator which
in css is the
colon
the string is is the value that we have
there and then we have a rule end
a rule ender ender's game coming up soon
uh
sponsor uh but uh
we add structure uh so
if you go back here uh you can see that
it's uh it's a very small css file it
actually would output nothing on on the
other end
uh but we have that and we turn it into
this we say this is a single node and
inside of it has two nodes inside of it
and that is of our name and a value
and so now we have this
this idea of this is a single node and
inside of our two smaller nodes
and the way the entire css file is going
to parse out is into these leaf nodes
right like this so you'll always have
like a variable name or a css value or a
css property and you can go deep into
your your tree which we'll talk about in
a second and everything reduces down
into these
very simple things they're just put all
in a list together uh or in a tree
together uh depending on how deep you go
css is actually not very deep uh
sas and compass and all that stuff they
actually allow you to nest a lot further
and so when you're parsing preprocessors
you actually do see like larger nesting
and so you have a css syntax tree inside
of a css syntax tree instead of a css
syntax tree
so this is uh more realistic uh for
um
another very small one but it actually
would output something uh we say like
our our outer
object is a style sheet and inside of it
it has some declarations right so style
sheets have declarations
uh first thing we do is we do that
the the the we set blue uh before so
i've omitted that section so this fits
on mostly a slide pretty close um
and so we've set that variable and then
we set the the left and right and so we
know what the the name is and we know
what the value is and then we have a
declaration and we say the selectors
here are p and dot stuff uh and so that
would whenever you compile that would be
p comma dot stuff and then there would
be the brackets and inside that are the
rules and the rules you have a list of
rules and so this is just going to be a
list of rule nodes
and so in this case it's color and value
so
uh this would just have a single value
uh if we wanted more rules we could have
you know background uh and then have
have that whole set of rules for
background and things like that uh
visually this is uh what you might write
uh in sas or stylus or less
i think the and syntax works in all of
them maybe someone probably knows uh but
in this case we're just saying we want
to modify the hover pseudo class of the
outer class so this is not valid css at
this point but it is valid sas and we're
just saying i want the original style of
a but i just want to change the hover
case
for
to be underlined in this case i'm trying
to simplify so that would actually be
kind of silly uh because you're not
sharing anything uh in the long run but
it's simple
uh so this becomes this so this is uh
our our object
at the bottom is the style sheet we have
a body node and we have an a node and
inside of that we have rules the color's
black one has text decoration and then
the hover is a new level
more nested so if you go back here you
can see even in the code the brackets
kind of represent
that nesting
uh and that
is an abstract syntax tree so
uh it's not
an ast is a kind of a scary word and
everyone kind of blank stare at you
unless
they've worked with them before
but it's actually
an easily breakdownable word that's
totally also a hard to break down word
but abstract means that there's no rules
you can make them however you want uh it
really should just be like arbitrary
syntax tree because
it's uh it's just like whatever you want
to do is cool as long as it's a tree
syntax implies that it's about syntax so
if you're parsing code then it's a
syntax tree and tree just means that
like
there are objects within objects so it's
like a very very vague term and it
almost means nothing other than that it
represents some sort of structure for
code
but these are generated by every
preprocessor or at least most so what
can we do
with this section so we no longer are
reading text
and we don't even have valid css yet
so we have this object that represents
our
preprocessor
data
and data is really important there
we can change the data we can read the
data
we can add to it we can do anything we
want
at that point as data it's much harder
to regex in
extra rules and regex out rules that you
don't want
than it is to just say like hey change
the rule of the third node to this new
thing or add another rule uh it's a
declarative way in code to add things in
rather than uh regex and and string
position and stuff
so uh there's a compilation phase uh
after this so
what it'll do first is reduce
your
preprocessor ast
into a css ast
so you have uh this asc this is the data
you have two nodes here the first one is
you're setting a variable blue to this
blue color that we've been using uh and
then we have a rule somewhere later that
wouldn't actually be that well i guess
you can set a variable inside of a
declaration
you have a rule and it sets the color to
that variable name blue and so this is
not this is not a valid css
node because there are no variables in
css yet um
and so we couldn't compile this into css
but what the compiler does first is
reduces the
ast from the preprocessor into one that
is valid in css so it would take this
store that blue was the variable and
then reduce it uh to just say hey this
node is the color of that color and so
you no longer have the invalid variable
node and now you have a totally valid
css node so you could compile that to
colon or color colon that blue color and
that would be totally valid so it does
this
recursively
until
you get back
to a valid css ast and then you compile
that to text
so our reduction goes from this
to this
and
it goes leaves to trunk and i call that
up the tree but that's kind of a weird
leaves to trunk would be down the tree i
don't really know i think there are
people who disagree with me
especially
really angrily on twitter
um
so
the recap of how that compilation step
works is first it takes this block and
it changes it into something like this
and i know that's ugly you don't have to
actually be able to read that this is a
declaration
uh it's got color in it and then there's
declare oh dick larson uh so
that's a special type of css node
it's too advanced
uh
but uh
so so you have essentially a declaration
inside of a declaration here and that's
invalid in css it's valid in sas and so
what you do is you first reduce that to
three separate declarations uh and
you'll notice the a and a hover are now
mixed in the second declaration and a
hover has its own third declaration with
the extra two characters of white space
that are bugging me
um
so and then you convert that to text and
since css knows how to take that ast and
turn it into text that's a very simple
uh
compilation step
and so this is what
this text from before
this was our original stuff we have the
extra inside declaration and we do those
few things and now we have two separate
declarations that make sense in css
so
in words it takes one type of text
converts it into a known but arbitrary
data format
then it converts that data into a
different but arbitrary and known data
format
and then it converts that back into text
and that's the entire
preprocessor
uh
world in a nutshell and so all of you
should be able to just write
preprocessors now
and that's the end of my talk
um
so this is uh these are the phases uh
you could probably break each one of
these down into a lot smaller parts but
really the only hard part is that
the rest is kind of like solves computer
sciency stuff right it's easy to write
parser expression grammars and like
compilers uh we've got a lot of them and
we can we can do better i'm sure but uh
there are tools that you can kind of
just use off the shelf to do
text to data and data to text
you have to kind of write the the
bindings but that's about it so the only
thing that
like
in sas or in stylus that people are
doing really is focusing on data one to
data two what data can i take in to
convert
to this regular css data that we know
about
so the hacking part of this is the fun
part
so what can we do
data one is very interesting because you
usually have the most amount of data
you're usually reducing data into data
two data two could be interesting as
well uh if you need to know something
about the css structure uh and i'll use
it a little bit in a in a demo but
data one has the most amount uh the most
dense information that you that you can
have
so just uh my my other bulleted list
here is uh some things you can do with
data one that i thought off the top of
my head that i won't necessarily
actually show you how but you can go
through those leaf nodes and you say
like oh i use that variable let me just
count up all the times that that shows
up and you can say like oh it turns out
i never used these 10 variables that i
declared at the top of my file and that
can be interesting
you can change variables in real time
you say well i know i set this as this
but i'm going to go change half of them
to a new value
just by replacing the dot value of that
node and then when it compiles it
doesn't know that you changed something
you can reduce duplicate code you can go
look for
duplicate selectors and and rules and
say like well let's get rid of these you
could write a linter
i think
nicole
wrote one of those
and
you can now put statistics and and do
all sorts of fun stuff so i'll show you
some some fun stuff
uh so as long as data one is valid when
you're done it doesn't matter what you
did to it so you could completely
replace it with a new
ast and then compile it and it would
just compile to your new ast
i'd probably be ill-advised so here's my
first uh example the important ties
uh
ast modifier uh so you take in data
which is an ast
and you usually have a type on
everything because that's how you know
what to do with it so we check to see if
it's a rule if it's a rule we change its
value
to have important at the end
um
is that does the bang go there
is it on the other side
really is that man um
i'm sick
so i'll blame that uh no it goes on that
side right someone tell me no it doesn't
all right man
css not a fan
anyways
so
you'll go through uh this rule and
you'll say
if this is a rule well
which it is because we're going through
this rule uh you'll add important to the
value and then whenever it gets printed
out that'll have important at the end so
if it already had important uh you're
kind of screwed we didn't check uh and
then we'll say uh everything is
recursive in a tree right so you'll say
uh my children
might be rules too if i'm not a rule uh
and then so go through each node
recursively down the tree and if it's a
rule change the value to have important
at the end of it
um and really in recursive functions you
should like return it and stuff like
that but in javascript we're passing
around the same object and it'll just
work sorry
uh yeah that's that whole one
here's uh the opposite uh the undo
intern work
uh
ast
so we're gonna go straight into the
children uh
of the asd and we're gonna see if uh the
child is a rule
and it matches on the string important
at all
then just return null
and essentially delete that node so if
if a rule has important in it no longer
put it
in the set of rules that we're gonna
send uh to the compiler uh otherwise uh
return the child uh and then do that
recursively and then we'll take out all
those uh null rules at the end with
compact
uh which is a non-standard array
function that i'm
allowing you to trust me on
and those rules if there were 10 rules
before and six of them had
important in them now you have four
rules and when they get compiled just
the four rules come out so you have
both ways to turn on
globally importance or to remove any
rule with an important you could also
just remove the
important tag which would probably may
be reasonable but just
write them don't write them to begin
with so this is every preprocessor every
preprocessor has this phase um
this is not unique to stylus or sas or
anything that we're doing uh up here
it
is
varying levels of difficulty to actually
um
get into this phase though in different
uh preprocessors rework is a pretty new
one uh
by tj uh holloway j chuck it's close
enough uh
vision media and uh he he wrote stylus
originally and uh rework was kind of
like based on what he learned from that
he wrote this uh and it is essentially
just
uh
like exposing the ast layer as soon as i
submitted this talk maybe like two days
later he put this out and i was kind of
bummed but it actually made the demo way
easier
so i was no longer bummed uh is that a
kerning
nightmare or what um
so let's go a little more real world uh
so compilation of styles is pretty fast
right like i can compile like that ten
line uh css or sas file in like
milliseconds right that's pretty cool uh
but it's not fast if you want like a
slider that changes a variable right you
can never hook this onto an unchange
event and have things update on the page
you gotta send the request back to the
server have it compile send the file
back up re-inject recalculate styles
that would never work you'd have to have
it on like a second you know max minimum
uh
delay on the change events
so
if you're building theme builder
which say what you will about the real
worldness of that but i had to do it um
you want a color picker and you want a
size slider for some of your variables
you don't necessarily want to say like
make this thing bigger you want to say
like make my
base color different right you want to
change all the places you're using base
color in your code and that's
signified by variables in your css files
and you want to do it in real time and
the only way to do that is to avoid
recompiling because the compile step is
just going to take too long
so
we'll go to my demo
so we have this
fun page i can actually
75 all right so we're running this this
is a page with a little bit of css i can
show you my
example css file this is the my css
file literally a dot my css it is my own
rework
css preprocessor which has
one feature which is variable so i've
turned on variables so i'm using bg
color for this background border radius
big border radius
that type of stuff and then in my
index.html file i have
a header and a subheader and then i
style that with with those things and
then
somewhere
that isn't open i pass the data for what
those variables should be and i won't
try and open that right now
so we have values for this and
this comes out as css on the other end
so now you can see the values
so this is example.css it comes out the
other end pre-compiled actually
pre-compile on load so each time it'll
do that and you can see you have a
background color here we have
more background colors and so those are
getting set
what i also added was an endpoint to add
json to the end of every single
css file and what that'll do is it'll
take the ast
go find every variable and then reduce
uh essentially flip the file on its head
so what we have here is data that says
this is the bg color variable this is
the app width variable this is the
border color and in here we have a list
of selectors that end up using
this variable and then the rules that
they use it on so we know that dot
container contains a border radius where
the value is big border radius and that
seems cool like we now have a list of
all our variables so that was pretty
easy to get
based on on
just going through the nodes and saying
is this a variable node and if it is add
it to this list and then you kind of
have to do some hacky stuff in order to
get the selectors back out uh depending
on your preprocessor
but we can pull in that data here
and that got way bigger
we can pull in that data here and we
have this thing i've injected on the top
and i i have all the code for this for
you that i'm not gonna walk through uh
because that's a fun demo uh but
essentially what we're doing here is we
go through those variables we list them
out here and then based on what they say
width or color i'll give you the correct
picker for them and also tell you how
many times they they were used and so bg
color is used twice
and we know the selector and we know the
rules so i'll use the selector real fast
to show you
uh the three pages on the three places
on the page that bg color actually gets
uh used at least which elements so this
is being used on the html element the
body element which i guess starts at the
top of this thing since i have a margin
on it
and then also bg collar is used as the
text color for leaf them alone
uh which is
more hilarious than you guys gave it
credit for save
and so we're using a single variable it
shows up in two selectors and it's on
three elements and this is data that you
can never see like where are my
variables being used in my page uh
that's pretty cool you you see like app
width is used on this you see border
color border radius all that stuff so
that's pretty cool
but also we can we can inject new styles
we know the selector we know the rule
and we know our new value that we want
to try out so we can pop up a color
picker and say this is bg color and just
inject a totally new style like so we're
not recompiling we're injecting a new
style like a style element and we'll put
the selector
bracket rule
colon and then whatever we're picking
from this color selector on a change
event so we can do this
straight off of our variables so this is
completely
generated from
the data inside of your ast you don't
have to program this somewhere else we
can add a new variable to our file it
will automatically show up in this list
so we can come in and change the app
width to something that's more
css friendly
change the border to
invariably if you give someone complete
control it looks like this every time
right this is my favorite doesn't it
like
that trips me out man
i'm not like nyquil right now but that's
that's good anyways
uh and then we can get a better header
color in there
and so that's that's my one example of
some crazy stuff uh that you can do
uh i have this available
at this url
uh
talk slash abusing dash preprocessor
dash asts and you can see that you had
to run an express app in order to do
that compilation step but you can kind
of see it's all well commented on on how
that works but
thank you guys
you